ظروف سياسيه واقتصاديه عاشتها بعض بلدان
العالمين العربي والاسلامي خلال السنوات
الماضيه تسببت وفق بعض الدراسات العلميه
في زياده الضغوط وما تبعها من شيوع
الاحباط وتنامي فرص الاصابه بالامراض
النفسيه المختلفه فما هي سبل الحفاظ على
السلامه النفسيه وكيف يمكن للانسان مواجهه
الضغوط التي يتعرض لها بشكل يومي في ظل
ظروف معيشيه صعبه
ما اسباب انتشار هذه الامراض او
الاضطرابات وما اسباب ايضا تراجع مؤشر
السعاده في دولنا العربيه برايك السبب
الاول مما تركه وباء كوفيد وجائحه كوفيد
التي انتشرت في عده بلدان عربيه ولم
نستطيع التخلص منها السبب الثاني يتعلق
بظروف
المعيشيه الضنك وكافه المسائل اليوميه
ارتفاع الاسعار البطال التي عاصفت بالعديد
من الفئات الاجتماعيه التغيرات المناخيه
التي للاسف تقسي عده فئات خاصه صغار
الفلاحين السبب الثالث الظروف السياسيه
المناخات السياسيه تقلص حريات التعبير
حالات
الثورات العربيه التي انتفضت ثم انتكست
الى غير ذلك كل اشواق الحريه التي للاسف
احبطت العامل الرابع والاخير هو عدم
القدره على التنشئه على قيم السعاده نحن
في اساليب التربيه وفي اساليب التنشئه
الاجتماعيه لنا بصفه عامه ترسانا من
الوسائل الضاغطه التي لا تتيح الحوار ولا
تتيح المرافقه النفسيه اثناء الازمات كيف
يمكن ان نفهم النمو الملحوظ مؤخرا في
العنف انتشار العنف في مختلف البلدان
العربيه يوما يفقد الانسان الشعور بالامان
يفقد الانسان الشعور بالثقه في المستقبل
يفقد الانسان الشعور
بالانتماء للمكان هو يعيش فيه ياتي سلوكا
الاخر اللي هو السلوك اللي يعني اسمح لي
اسميه سلوك الحيواني لان عندما تكون
الامور غير واضحه تماما الانسان يعود الى
الفكره الرئيسيه الموجوده داخله وهي
البقاء للاقوى فبالتالي يبتدي يدخل في هذه
المظاهر السلوكيه ليكون فيها شيء من العنف
شيء من تحقيق الغلبه والاستحواذ على شيء
اعلم بان غدا صعب فانا اريد ان اؤمن لنفسي
ولاسرتي
الغد كيف اسهمت الاوضاع التي يعيشها
العالم العربي في السنوات الاخيره في خلق
ما يعرف بالهشاشه النفسيه في الهشاشه
النفسيه هي عدم قدره الفرد على التحمل
وقدرته ايضا على التصرف السليم وفق المنطق
والعقل فاعتقد ان الفرد العربي كما قلت
اصبح اكثر عرضه الى شاشه نفسيه اي عدم
سيطرته على انفعالاتها عدم قدرته على
اتخاذ القرار المناسب عدم قدرته على رد
الفعل الذي يتناسب مع المثيرات الخارجيه
بهذا الشكل اصبحت الجماعات والفئات
الواسعه في المجتمعات العربيه تلجا في
الكثير من الاحيان الى ردود افعال متشنجه
والى ردود افعال فيها الكثير من العنف
الكثير من الانتواء والانسحاب خصوصا وان
ما نسميه السرديات التي يعيش عليها
المواطن العربي تلك الاحلام الكبيره في
التقدم في الوحده في الازدهار في الرخاء
الاقتصادي السرديات الكبرى والانتظارات
الكبرى تراجعت ان لم اكن اقول لا شك ان
الواقع الاقتصادي والسياسي في اي مكان في
العالم ينعكس بشكل رئيسي على التوازن
النفسي للفرد واحنا بنعرف بانه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه على اختلافها والتي تبدا من
الحاجات الفسيولوجيه
وتمر بحاجات الامن والسلامه والحب
والانتماء يعني مرتبطه بشكل رئيسي بالواقع
الاقتصادي والسياسي فاذا ما كان هذا
الواقع يعني يشي بالقلق والخوف من
المستقبل معنى ذلك بانه الفرد يعيش حاله
غير منضبطه وربما يفشل ايضا في التكيف
النفسي الاجتماعي السليم لذلك يعني بعض
الاشخاص ربما يلجا احيانا الى الانتحار
وربما يعني يلجا الى ايقاع الاذى على
الاخرين او ممتلكاتهم
ما واقع الدراسات النفسيه دراسات الصحه
النفسيه دراسات الطب النفسي الابحاث
المتعلقه في ذلك في عالمنا العربي للاسف
الواقع التعليمي او الواقع العلمي في
مجتمعاتنا العربيه هو واقع متدني في الوقت
الحالي تاليا سينعكس على مستوى الابحاث
والدراسات الموجوده ما يصرف على التعليم
في مجتمعاتنا العربيه غالبا موجه الى
الشكل وليس الى المضمون بشكل الجامعه
المباني
الخدمات الخدمات المقدمه المميزات اللي
يحصل عليها الطالب لكن عمليه البحث العلمي
والسبق العلمي وان احنا نكون اصحاب
الرياضه في تقديم العلم هذه ما زلنا فيها
متاخرين جدا انا كنت ذات يوم مسؤول في
المكتب الوطنيه واعلم تماما انه ما يصدر
في تونس سنويا يعني لا يتجاوز عدد الاصابع
حول القضايا المتعلقه بالصحه هناك نقص
فادح في الانتاج المعرفي العلمي الدقيق
حول الظواهر النفسيه واساسا حول السلامه
النفسيه والصحه النفسيه بصفه عامه في
العالم العربي دراسات النفسيه العربيه لا
توازي الدراسات النفسيه الغربيه لا من حيث
الكم ولا من حيث النوع لانه احنا في
العالم العربي المحجمين بالفقر اولا
وثانيا لا يوجد لدينا مراكز دراسات علميه
متخصصه ولا يوجد دعم للبحث العلمي وماذا
عن واقع الانفاق على مرافق الصحه النفسيه
في مجتمعاتنا العربيه والاسلاميه في تونس
اولا ما ينفق حول الساحه العموميه يتراجع
وهذا ايضا ربما في العديد من المجتمعات
العربيه
نخصصه للصحه بصفه عامه مقارنته الى انشطه
اخرى هو ضئيل جدا واخر الاقسام التي تدشر
في المستشفيات نعطي قسم القلب ونعطي قسم
الامراض المعده وقسم العظام وقسم ولكن اخر
الاقسام التي تضاف بالحد الهدنه هي اقسام
الطب النفسي مليون دولار اريد ان اشتري
فيها علاج للسرطان للقلب للسكر وللامراض
النفسيه لو انت وزير الصحه دكتور علي كم
ستعطي الامراض النفسيه مقارنه بامراض
السرطان والقلب
هل يمكن القول بوجود رابط بين التكنولوجيا
الحديثه وادمان مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وبين زياده احتمالات الاصابه بالمرض
النفسي نعم انا باعتقادي تلعب التكنولوجيا
دور مهم جدا في نمو مناخ فلنقل مناخا
نفسيا واجتماعيا
مناسبا او مواطن لانتشار كل هذه المظاهر
القلق الاحباط التوتر الضغط الشبكات
الاجتماعيه التواصل تلغي كما قلت الاخرين
في العلاقه المباشره علاقه النظر علاقه
اللمس علاقه الشمس للاسف هذه حواسنا وهي
منافذنا التي ننظر ننظر اليه لك اذا
اغلقناها بين قوسين اغنقنا عيوننا وغلقنا
حواسنا وكل كل ذواتنا صبت على الشاشات
وصبت على هذه الحواسيب للاسف فانه سيقع
افكار الموارد النفسيه والذهنيه تعلمنا
كما قلت يصبح
ويصبح نوع من الانتواء على الذات وبالتالي
علاقاتنا مع الاخرين تتدهور قدراتي ايضا
على الاستيعاب وعلى الانصات وعلى الحوار
كلها تتجمد وتنكمش للاسف كيف يمكن للانسان
ان يحمي نفسه من هذه الضغوطات من هذه
الامراض المنتشره قبل عمر بن الخطاب رضي
الله عنه وارضاه خشوشنوا فان النعم لا
تدوم فاذا عمر بن الخطاب قاعد يقول لنا او
يحاول يعلمنا بان احنا ضروري ان يكون هناك
نوع من التمرين الذاتي لعمليه كيف اتعامل
مع الواقع والمتغيرات اللي ممكن ان تحدث
فيه حتى لو
المستقبل جاء بعكس ما كنت اتوقع لكن انا
راح اكون مرتاح او سعيد بما قدمت وحاولت
[موسيقى]